12 hidden features of my japanese house
full house tour video here point number
one roof tiles one of the main features
of the house
is this central courtyard that the house
wraps around there are these roof tiles
traditional japanese roof tiles in this
corner of the courtyard and what's
special about these is that these were
actually made by my wife's grandfather
he made these for a living my wife and i
had seen people use roof tiles in this
way sort of recycling them to create
this zen aesthetic in architecture we
wanted to do the same thing while also
sort of you know injecting her family's
dna into the house point number two
hidden full-length mirror so right now
we're in the gangkong of the house the
entryway to the house but this is
actually the guest gengong we don't keep
our shoes here such that when guests
come over they can smoothly come up into
the house and not have to walk over our
shoes and other other things we keep all
of those things
in this room this is the family gang and
when we come to the house we use this
space but what's special about this
space is that on the other side of this
door
hidden inside of the door itself is this
full-length mirror you can check your
appearance before you leave and this
also enables us to
not then need
one of these standing full-length
mirrors that takes up a bunch of space
somewhere else in the house point number
three
so we have a roomba and the reason for
that is because except for the guest
room all the floor space of this house
is on the first floor of the house which
is the type of house in which a roomba
really shines we knew that we wanted one
early on but we had also heard a bunch
of horror stories from people that
bought these five or six hundred dollar
robot vacuum cleaners but then ended up
not really using them because when
you're not using them they've got these
charging stations and the room by itself
is actually surprisingly large and they
end up taking like
up an entire corner like this awkward
section of your living room then you
have to like step over it and you bump
into it and it ends up being more of a
hassle than it actually is but because
we knew we wanted one early on what our
architect suggested was this we've got
this little storage closet right here
and he said we could cut out just the
bottom of that closet put an outlet in
there for the charging station you never
have to see it but then you would still
get all the benefits of the roomba and
when it's all done it just goes back
home by itself point number four hidden
cable drawer so one of the things that i
love so much about this architect is how
he hides things as a youtuber i have a
bunch of
you know usb cables hdmi cables audio
cables and taking a cue from the uh
taking a clue taking a cue from the
architect i installed this drawer
under this desk itself so i keep all you
know my camera trinkets and stuff like
that that uh
i use maybe once or twice a year and
can't really throw away they're all
under there and they're out of sight and
out of mind when i'm not using them so
point number five is office lighting
we're currently in my office and in the
original tour video i talked a little
bit about how these
side lights and these light rails along
the ceiling enabled me to get rid of the
giant light and tripod that i had in my
previous office that took up like half
my room what i didn't talk about in that
video is how
you can actually adjust the temperature
and
brightness of all these lights as well
so i've got this little
switcher over here and i can press these
buttons to
make these lights dimmer
or
change the temperature on these and
oftentimes what i do at night is
i'll turn everything except except these
side lights off and it kind of gets me
in that mood before bed if i've got one
of my youtube buddies here we can use
this flexibility to shoot another video
in a different part of the office okay
so point number six is cable management
this is something that i'm
very very pleased with how it turned out
i've got a fairly intense setup when it
comes to cables but you shouldn't be
able to see
most of them and the main reason for
that is because although
most outlets are at that height i
believe this is the standard height for
an outlet in japan about 10 or so
centimeters off the ground the height of
the two outlets that are under this desk
is different from that of all the other
outlets in the house you can't really
see them
unless you either duck down or the desk
is very very high so maybe now you can
see the ethernet cord if you kind of
squat down here
you can see what's
actually going on in here up from above
when i'm working i can't see almost any
of those cables so i'm really happy with
how this turned out point number seven
is hidden storage so there's hidden
storage somewhere in this room
where is it
that's right it's under the tatami mat
so when you move or replace a tatami mat
you use a sharp kind of needle-like
thing like this
to stab the side of it rather than
making a big scratch along the top of it
you want to kind of stab the side like
that and then you can lift it up
here in my office
right here
there's a storage space
a great place for again just storing
various things that i don't want to
think about but can't throw away okay so
we're currently in the kitchen and this
behind me is the pantry and there's a
door here
for when you want to
block off the pantry my wife has a
little desk down here so if she wants
some personal time and wants to you know
get some refuge from me but point number
eight is actually
this
on the other side of the door frame
there's this chalkboard that pops out
and the whole purpose of this is it
gives my wife a way to write something
down quickly when she's in the middle of
cooking something and or to reference
what she's written down previously even
when she has greasy hands you know you
don't want to take out your expensive
thousand dollar iphone if you've got
grease all over your hands or if you've
got flour all over your hands or
something like that but if it's chalk
you know there's a little piece of chalk
that we keep over here and she can just
write things down quickly and then again
look back and forth between the kitchen
and right here in the middle of cooking
really just kind of follows the
out of sight out of mind design language
of the house in the original tour video
i talked about
these these shogi japanese paper doors
that come out of the walls great way to
change the atmosphere of the room but
it's also highly practical because it
allows us to block out the extremely
intense japanese summer sun it gets so
hot in japan during the summer that i i
shaved my head i'm balding that's
another reason but it's hot we've got
these paper doors for
this window and then that much larger
window over there maybe you can get a
shot of that real quick
but then point number nine is actually
this these electric roll screens for the
windows up above same basic idea this
gives us a practical easy way to block
out that intense summer sun without
overworking our ac during the summer we
could have gone with um you know
a string as well but we were a little
worried about having we've got two
daughters and two small daughters that
are constantly you know running along
this kind of area of the house and we
were thinking you know they might get
like kind of strung up in in that or get
like an arm caught on that then it could
yank the entire thing down from the
ceiling so we went electric and uh it
just also again kind of cleans up the
space much more there's no
there aren't these two big strings that
go all the way from the ceiling all the
way to the floor currently in the
family closet area one of the things
that we didn't talk about in the
original tour video is
this this is a liner that goes up to a
different space entirely this is
actually a storage space and i'm not
going to show you guys because
being a storage space it's kind of just
full of junk but i do have a little bit
of footage of my friend norm from tokyo
lens climbing up and reacting to the
space up there so i'll just drop that in
here
[Music]
oh
it's actually really spacious up here
emergency supply yeah yeah yeah i
i love
how
oh there's there's a land
all right so we're currently in the
laundry area that leads into the onsen
the bathing slash hot springs area and
point number 11 is
is this so this is the drying rack for
the clothes that you can wash but not
dry using the washer slash dryer being
adjustable it's really great for us
because i'm really tall which means that
at this height you know i would run into
it but
any higher than this if it was set it
would be very difficult for my wife to
use but beyond that
if we've got you know a bunch of wet
clothes that are hanging here it makes
this area very very difficult to use so
we hang up the clothes
and then with the whole the clothes
hung on this we can then raise it up
wash our faces in the morning or brush
our teeth or whatever we need to do do
the next batch of laundry here that's
kind of the max height for hanging
clothes but if you press the button
again and hold it it goes
all the way up into the ceiling so this
is the guest room this is the place
where my youtube buddies come and uh
stay overnight we've got one of these
ceiling lights kind of more traditional
japanese ceiling light up here that you
can you know turn off and turn on and
off using a remote but the kind of the
grand finale of this video point number
12 i believe
is this so this
light up here is actually this product
called a pop in aladdin it is a ceiling
light but it's also a wireless projector
thing about this guest room guest rooms
in general is that they're wonderful for
when you have guests but they're kind of
a dead space for when you don't have a
guest we actually have this projector
from our old house we don't really like
tvs that much they're a little bit too
easy to turn on and turn off and we've
got kids and we'd prefer if they're not
watching tv constantly the architect
said okay let's turn the guest room
into a theater room as well when you
close this door that little window that
window over there and then you also turn
off
that light
it puts this big big image up onto the
wall but it just hooks up to a standard
japanese ceiling light outlet and then
again it's all wireless so we've got our
wi-fi router downstairs that's currently
beaming us uh you know chris broad and
we can
sit back and
use this
beanbag chair over here and relax and
get some you know nice family time watch
disney movies or harry potter movies or
whatever we want to do when the guest is
here there's not a giant tv that's
blocking up half of half of the room and
a bunch of cables all right but that's
the video i hope that you guys enjoyed
it for those that don't know i teach
japanese pronunciation in pitch accent
over on patreon i'll leave a link down
in the description below alright see you
guys soon bye
[Music]